[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel awesome
Zorba report your source for everything
happening around the world of pop
culture and entertainment news
I'm Heather Ruth and I'm Ana Wade and
this is your news for Monday March 5th
first up we wanted to say we are
recording before the Academy Awards so
amazing how many things one
congratulations you guys I'm so
surprised that that one thing that
happened who's all that coming
you know the classic Oscars so congrats
to all of the winners and we will be
telling you everything else that
happened this week yeah so first of all
we got new is about that Rocketeer
reboot that we've been hearing about and
it is confirmed that there's going to be
a female lead now playing The Rocketeer
and it's going to be animated and on
Disney Junior the target audience of
ages 2 to 7 yeah seems like a really odd
choice there I mean it's a little
unclear about whether this is a whole
different project that is being run
right now or if it is The Rocketeer
reboot that we have been promised and
put reboot here in quotation marks
because it doesn't seem all that similar
to the movie so yeah it seems like it's
a weird choice an audience of 2 to 7
seems like the strangest choice of all
here
I mean maybe it'll be good maybe they're
trying to bring in a whole new
generation of kids here into the
Rocketeer and experiencing it but it
still just seems like an odd fit in an
odd choice yeah they're going to be each
episode is going to be 211 minute short
and um stories with a musical number an
original song in every
so I like that a musical rocketeers
Sakura I'm on board
maybe the older audience but yeah mmm
interesting it seems like just such a I
know I've said this like twice already
but it's such a strange choice I'm
really not excited okay but if you think
about Steven universe and Adventure Time
on Cartoon Network those shows kind of
fit that shorter format with occasional
music numbers and they're great so maybe
this could be great maybe but it's not
for the same audience that's what kids
me know that's closer to Teen Titans go
audience oh no please no right let's not
Teen Titans go the Rockettes here oh no
no that would be awful no I can't I
can't
yeah so it's gonna follow the story of
Kit mhmmm girl who receives the
Rocketeer jet pack as a present and then
takes on the mantle and her and her
friends go on some great adventures okay
that learning lesson I could do budding
I'm I'm not sure where this is going I
have to look yet though because I could
go for a musical racketeers sounds
excellent that's right up my alley
you've checked in multiple boxes for me
but I mean I don't know if I'm I don't
think I'm gonna watch it just because I
don't have a two to seven year-old child
nor do I have access to Disney Junior
and it never stopped me
I will definitely watch it because I
need to know that it's good yeah well
that'll be coming to Disney Junior in
2019 no release date or anything for it
yet just that it's in the mix it's in
the works
fingers crossed you guys it's coming
whether you like it or not
also this week Netflix announced a few
things with the newest season 3 of stir
Ranger things
yay do you remember Erica yes yes
Lucas's little sister who stole every
scene she was in so sassy
well yeah Ferguson the actress who
played her they
is now being bumped up to a regular
reoccurring character on the show yeah
yes she's gonna be amazing let's be
honest also in the release it said that
she was going to have kind of her own
posse like an army of her own friends
so that's yes please give me some snappy
dialogue with all of the all of the
young friends that sounds great
I am in for that also too this season
they're going to be adding a new
character plead by Maya Thurmond Hawk
who you might recognize from BBC's
Little Women that we talked about on the
show before she is going to be added as
a bored alternative girl oh we already
do that with Max oh and wasted max
wasted max yeah come on she could have
been great she was good she wasn't great
and she also didn't really have her own
reason for doing things
come on Russo brothers are we gonna do
this again with this new female
character cuz I'd rather not is she
going to be a love interest and no thank
you is she going to be a femme rival and
no thank you
just give her her own purpose on the
show that's what I want like 11 is great
ah but max you wasted her what a great
character so worried about that
character but excited for season 3
nonetheless oh yes Oh stranger thing yes
Gary you're in stranger than ever before
oh my gosh very excited also this week
it was announced that New Mutants is
going into reshoots which in and of
itself is okay movies have done reshoots
and they've succeeded because of it
however apparently that's because
they're adding a whole nother character
that's insane yeah cuz it already had a
final cut and was pushed back a whole
year so we're it's still coming we've
announced before but it's still coming
out February 22nd on 2019 but now we're
adding a whole new character and that's
worrisome that's
just bonkers yes for me and we knew what
was gonna go into reshoots once they
push back the date it was announced that
they're going into reshoots to change
the tone to be right scarier or
something like that which was already
worrisome yeah but a whole new year and
we don't know who or what actor is
playing that character no idea so it's a
mysterious new character played by a
mysterious actor who knows not us nah
it's I'm worried it's a mess that just
told me that it's gonna be a mess yeah I
have to add a whole new character so
screen yeah I know I guess the testing
screenings are just not going great it
was a poster come out next month right
it was supposed to be April 18th like
2018 yeah it was done and pushed back
we've heard multiple reasons why but now
a whole nother character well I've seen
to me
yeah hmm but this week we got news of a
movie being pushed forward a little
movie you may have heard about in
infinity war oh the New Avengers movie
that's awesome oh it's getting pushed up
a week which is exciting I'm so excited
to be able to see this movie a week
early the only thing that I know some
people have said that is negative about
this if some people have already like
gotten off work on the fourth or the
third of getting ready to be able to buy
their movie ticket and see it that day
and know it's irrelevant
but it's great news for most of us I'm
sorry if you know it's ruined but it's
fine you're fine it's gonna be such that
shipped with someone we're all gonna get
to see it early and the reason that most
people are thinking that has been moved
up is that the April 27th release date
was the release date in the UK and there
are some other release dates earlier in
Europe and I'm sure they're doing this
so that no spoilers are hitting the
internet before the US audience can even
get a chance to see it this is why we
can't have nice things
spread but it is a great call on their
part because I am positive it would have
been stolen spoiled Oh pirated it's
gotta finish or piracy issues and it's a
very smart move on their part to move it
up to avoid those piracy
there was also some chatter that it
might also be so that solo could get a
little bit of breathing room so solo was
also coming out in May and since both
properties are owned by Disney the
thought process is if infinity Wars is
in April then it won't conflict at all
with solo so that people won't have to
decide who do I go see Avengers or solo
because most people are probably gonna
go see Avengers given given choice a
little worried about solo so yeah
that's coming out sooner rather than
later I like toki announced it to on the
web so cute with Robert Downey jr. and
if we can call a movie about sweet cute
yes so they the official Marvel Studios
Twitter had posted that you know how
hyped are you for infinity Wars and
Robert Downey jr. came in was like hey
maybe I could see a little bit earlier
and Marvel Studios Twitter was like
anything for you mister stark and then
he's like how about some friends by the
way my friends are the world different
one but everyone I'm going everyone to
see it okay great here you go I love I
love a good announcement yeah
also this week we got to see a trailer
for the new wreck-it Ralph - which is
also Disney it is called Rekha 12-2
record Ralph breaks the Internet yes yes
so instead of just being in arcade game
vanellope and Ralph's get into the
internet connection and get to see what
the rest of us experience right on the
wee-fee so I I did enjoy some of the
like little things in the trailer like
the little clickbait characters that
were like hey look at this list number
six will surprise you also the kitten
picture at the art auction was really
hilarious
we all know I mean I have a cat let's be
real we look at a lot of pictures on of
cats
yes so hit close to home also there was
that little game the little girl was
playing on her like little app I'm
guessing there next to the Internet
where you feed like a bunny pancakes or
kitten a milkshake yeah and then Ralph
comes in and just like forces pancakes
on to that poor bunny and then we hear a
little pop we didn't see the bunny
explode but the bunny exploded you guys
and that little girls scream it tells us
that there was some graphicness to it oh
yes that was a trumped ice cream mmm all
the gore happens offstage classic yes so
we didn't get much from this trailer I
will say I was expecting a lot more from
this trailer so it was a little bit of a
teaser I would need more than like a
full-on like yes I'm gonna see that yeah
I wonder why I mean I love some vanilla
pea but I was a little it was a little
underwhelming but I'm sure they didn't
want to release all the good jokes
either which makes sense right because
honestly I'm so good to get and we can
still see that in theaters on
Thanksgiving yes on their Thanksgiving
release I think that's gonna be it from
us here guys we're running out of time
but if there's anything we must let us
know in the comments down below I know
all the Oscar stuff already don't worry
we know we know but if you feel
necessary let us know anyway in the
comments down below or on social media
Heather oh where is that for you you can
find me on Twitter at Heather ruse
Instagram at a truce or twitch twitch TV
flash Heather ruse and you can find me
on Facebook as I Anna Wade or everywhere
else as awesome Ayanna and we will see
you tomorrow on top 5 and next week here
same time same place in the meantime can
you beam us up
[Applause]
you